seen a lot of comedians on Tick Tock
yeah Matt Rife the amount of money that
he has to be making right now because
he's been over one minute millionaire my
guess he's probably making a million a
month but he deserves that Matt Rife was
somebody that I knew for a very long
time how did you meet him he's no he's a
local you know they've got a comic that
we would see at gigs and stuff I mean
he's a kid that did the business he has
Street Credibility because I know he did
the the deal you know when people don't
do the deal I don't have respect for it
what do you mean by the deal there's got
to be some suffering yeah you know what
I mean if you want to be a stand-up you
got to come to LA or New York and go
through that process I didn't no money
no one knew who I was they treated me
like and I looked at everyone I
want you'll see one day